on démarre en indre-et-loire chez david
l'agriculteur céréaliers qui prépare
l'hiver bienvenue sur la ferme
les outils sont plaints de terre et
avant qu'il ne soit mis sous les hangars
et au sec
j'enlève toute la terre pour éviter que
les outils ne pourrisse la nature est au
repos et david surveille ses plantations
là je viens voir au milieu des champs
mais je fais un tour de plus rapides
comme ça avec le quad s'il n'y a pas d'
attaques de limaces cette petite limaces
va venir croquer les jeunes feuilles
doublé ça peut être aussi des lapins ou
des lièvres donc ça demande une
surveillance pendant l'hiver se met en
automne ces céréales ont besoin de cette
période de froid
il ya certains végétaux ou ce moment
c'est une période de maturité
je veux parler d'un champignon très rare
qui se cultive ici dans la région
la truffe et je vous embarque avec moi
découvrir l'exploitation de serge
desazars il est truffé culte heures dans
la région de chinon c'est parti
à une heure de route de chez lui david a
rendez vous ce matin avec un passionné
qui a tout quitté pour devenir
trufficulteurs
nous voici arrivés sur l'exploitation de
serge ici derrière moi on a sa truffière
avec ses chaînes ici on a son matériel
et je crois savoir qu'il est à
l'intérieur en train de préparer ses
truffes pour ses clients oui c'est
évident que vois-tu très bien pu me
recevoir
merci de nous recevoir bah écoute
bienvenue et ça sent déjà très très bon
on est en plein dedans de la récolte a
déjà bien commencé ça c'est ce qu'on a
ramassé hier et on a déjà des truffes
bien bien noir alors qu'on est
mi-décembre à peine regarde cela les
fait l'effet du 2è d'un parfum
fantastique
déjà qu'on a des odeurs ici dans la
pièce qui se dégage mal partout mais
donc là on est là on est vraiment sur la
truffe noire va tuber melanosporum après
ça les autruches faut savoir qu'il ya 27
espèces de truffes différentes elles
vont tout avoir un parfum différent plus
ou moins important bon tu vas me montrer
comment tu tu arrives à ce résultat
parce que anciens directeurs de grandes
marques de prêt-à-porter serge desazars
s'est installée en 2011 dans la
propriété familiale pour se lancer dans
son nouveau métier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très envieux de ton look quand même
serge qu'est ce qu'il faut pour aller
cave est allé récolter la truffe voilà
c'est vrai que l'univers de la mode dans
lequel j'étais avant est très très loin
on est d'abord opérationnel on a la
besace pour les truffes et enfin le plus
important parce que les chiens
fonctionne comme ça c'est la petite
récompense à la fayette aller oui allez
on va chercher le profit a compris de
foyers de la fête
ouais on va chercher plus
je